je suis passionné des engins sportifs
donc ce sont des modèles qui me plaisent
beaucoup mais défaut du moins je ne peux
pas me le procurer donc je me suis dit
je peux le construire et je me suis
lancé dans la construction
[Musique]
la majorité des pièces utilisées c'est
dans les récupérations donc sur cette
caisse vous allez voir des pièces venant
des bus il y a aussi des pièces venant
des Titans des motos des véhicules
[Musique]
moi j'ai eu mon bac à 4 ans 2016 et
après le bac moi je me suis lancé dans
l'entrepreneuriat la vente
et réparation des téléphones ordinateurs
donc c'est déjà je suis donc c'est grâce
à ça j'ai pu
rassembler nous sommes pour la
conception de celle-ci
[Musique]